today we're gonna build up a complete
bike the secret about building bikes is
that it's not really all that hard if
you have the right tools we're here at
American cycling in San Francisco and
obviously we have all the right tools
here behind us so this should be pretty
easy and something making it even easier
is that we're building this up with
Shimano di2 which is electronic shifting
and it sounds more complex
technologically it probably is but it's
actually even easier to build up to buy
50 i2 so we're gonna walk through all
the steps on that and show you how to
build up a button so the first step will
be putting the fork and headset together
on the bike so that we have something to
start mounting everything on to so we'll
insert the fork into the head tube and
insert the bearings and clamp everything
down to the fork is in place the next
step will be inserting the bottom
bracket bearings and the crank set and
this frame actually has press-fit
bearings which makes things even easier
we don't actually have to insert the
bearings as you can see they're in here
already we can just insert the crank and
go all right let's not the handlebars in
the shifters now
now we're going to mount the front and
rear derailleurs which is a very simple
step you just bolt these into place
the holes are already here now we're
going to mount the battery and run the
wires from the shifters down to the
trailers this will take a little bit of
time it's not complex we just have to
route everything correctly we'll run the
wires from the shifters down to the
derivatives something that electronic
shifting allows you to do is push shift
buttons kind of wherever you want
there's really you're only limited by
the length of your cables so these are
remote shifters for the rear derailleur
and they mount on top of the bar here
and if you've ever been climbing a long
hill and you want a shift it's kind of
hard to reach down into the drops when
you want to be riding up here on the top
of the bars so this allows you to shift
with your hands up where you have them
when you're climbing you're climbing
you're right here you just reach down
here and push these buttons and you're
shifting up and down next we're going to
mount the chain and cassette we'll have
to cut the chain to length which we have
special tools for and then put the
cassette on the rear wheel we put the
wheels on and tune everything up and
we've got a bike
what we're doing now is setting the high
and low limits on the derailleur which
is something you have on any derailleur
and these are just two screws that vary
mechanic mechanically keep the
derailleur from going too far in or too
far out and it's just a matter of
turning these screws in to stop the
whole trailer housing from moving so
instead of having to do cable tension
which is how you generally tune a rear
derailleur we're just holding this
button down and the computer will do it
for us
so we're finished we've built up a
complete bike from bare frame to ride up
a bike pretty simple we ran into a few
hiccups this always happens with the
bike but as I said as long as you have
the right tools you can fix anything